ein weiteres Problem ist die
Digitalisierung sie ist in dieser Welt
noch nicht angekommen alle
Verwaltungsleistungen sollten eigentlich
bis 2022 digital sein das war letztes
Jahr ich denke mal diese Deadline
schaffen sie bestimmt nicht mehr es ist
hier wie ein paralleles Universum finde
ich alles steht hier noch auf Papier
wirklich in sogenannten Akten ich zeige
euch das mal das ist für normale
Menschen voll interessant also das hier
ist die Akte und hier schaut mal
man kann die nicht größer machen weil
die nicht digital ist das ist hier wie
300 vor Christus im Mittelalter ich
schwöre hey Frau
ist das ein Faxgerät das ist ein Locher
man lernte so viel
[Musik]